afortunado
por segunda vez en menos de un mes hay
manifestaciones contra el gobierno de
jair bolsonaro en varias ciudades de
brasil estamos en el centro del río de
janeiro y a los lamazón fuera bolsonaro
más vacunas y más ayudas económicas del
estado para hacer frente a los estragos
causados por la pandemia de coronavirus
[Música]
el gobierno revolucionario adoptó en
base a discursos obscurantistas una
postura que le llevó a perseguir la
inmunidad de rebaño conseguido no está
precisamente preocupado con la cantidad
de personas que van a morir por causa de
eso está matando al pueblo brasileño
negando la importancia de la ciencia y
de la vacuna
él no puede continuar donde está es un
monstruo genocida tiene que salir del
poder necesitamos derribarlo
la nota no es un aprieto
calles de brasil a aumentar el vídeo
desde la condición parlamentaria sobre
la pandemia ha recibido investigar a
varios ministros y consejeros del monzón
ya lope del senado
en calidad de testigos además algunos
senadores estudiante hay supuestos
jurídicos para investigar al propio
amontonaron por su supuesta
responsabilidad en la muerte de medio
millón de personas por plaza de
coronavirus